sozusagen und das müsste an gewesen
sondern es gibt keine nachverhandlungen
sie sehen ich bin wieder da und ich
werde mich auch von solchen so dämlichen
aktionen nicht davon abhalten lassen
weiter für die linke aktiv und engagiert
politik zu machen
ich habe mich sehr gefreut über die
vielen solidaritäts ausdrücke und und
bekundungen die ich bekommen habe das
tat gut auch auf dem parteitag
und ich muss sagen eigentlich schlimmer
als die ganze torte finde ich die
beleidigung mit frau von storch auf eine
ebene gestellt worden zu sein
das ist echt eine unverschämtheit und
ich finde das zeigt eigentlich nur dass
da offensichtlich völlige politische
analphabeten am werk waren habe
strafanzeige gestellt
darüber denke ich noch nach